tu mets bien alors on va faire on va
vraiment vous interviewez là c'est parti
alors avant vous étiez vous étiez
logisticiens chez bouygues et vous vous
étiez vendeur de vêtements galerie sava
alors quand vous êtes rencontrés
eric vous avez déclaré on n a pas d
accord s'était déclaré c'est vrai j'ai
fait une bonne mais il a déclaré je me
suis retrouvé allongé par terre à rire
j'ai mal au ventre comme si soudain mon
corps si des fois soudain mon corps me
parler c'était une première expérience
sexuelle mais abdominale
ces dix awsat a dit c'est trop fort il
dit
oui vous avez dit intrigue aussi vous
sur la rencontre quoi donc voilà vous
avez dit ramzy s'étaient non mérité si
c'est moi qui parle
non mais bon c'est rare analyse ardisson
eric le disses vite c'était la première
fois qu'un mec me faisait rire je me
suis dit grâce à lui je me remplir les
poches mais moi je l'interromps mais
marine est venu en pyjama mais jamais
rien de propre chez moi j'ai déménagé
parce qu'une prof mais c'est un coup de
propre que j'irai j'aime bien beau mais
elle est brillante aqmi
bah oui elle est quand même valeur
nouveau look et des chambres de gbon
premier sketch avez écrit votre premier
sketch oui tellement que le vidéo nous a
chassés
c'était chez hamburger pourrait on
écrire burger king le premier c'est vrai
que c'est vrai et on s'est fait virer on
était pourtant on était au premier étage
et le mec est venu d'en bas il est venu
nous chercher une également brouillé
ouais il a dit avec un accent ce qui
n'était pas de débat de chez nous de
cette région dix points des trucs comme
ça
alors aujourd'hui vous avez énormément
de succès comme on vient de le voir ou
l'incroyable la chance incroyable
c'est incroyable et jamais eu cinq
inconnus super connue si les poubelles
alors éric vous dites moi aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que la france est
devenue mon quartier tout le monde me
sourit ouais c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai c'est à dire on se balade moi
j'étais en corse cet été en vacances
c'est bon ça
c'est encore cet été et c'est marrant
parce qu'il est bon il y avait la
boulangère chômage alors le chat gna gna
et comme si c'était des gens que j'avais
vu la veille qui connaissent ma vie un
peu et tout ça alors ne venez pas vous
applaudissez quand il ya la pub
autant là quand un truc bien personne
n'applaudit pas croyable il a pas tort
avec son cousin ramzi le monde peut pas
gagner
eric plus donc j'ai l'impression que la
france est devenue son quartier d'une
certaine façon son entier car en verlan
langage des jeunes voilà tu es assis sur
une chaise et vous vous dites je me
souviens il ya quelques années les gens
changer de trottoir ce qu'il veut croire
alors il sert et leur sac à main ouais
je te jure c'est vrai quoi tu croises et
je croyais déjà enfin bon c'est normal
dans les trois heures et leurs sacs à
tirer non mais bon oui je sais comment
ça se passe entre vous alors celle
indiquant comme à lundi toujours à mais
ça va non ça des toits tirent bien le
mans soit la forme non non ça va c'est à
dire c'est vrai que caf lundi au qui se
séparent oui c'est ça bah oui 2 3 ans
machin et ça tient nous ça tiens on se
pardonne beaucoup mais ça veut pas dire
qu on s'embrouille pas un symbole comme
tout couple mais mais mais ça alors vous
dites tous les deux je finis ma phrase
excuse-moi respect car ils devaient non
je disais que on se pardonne beaucoup
salaire de chacun on a des choses à se
reprocher et surtout son passé en
quarante ans après son passage est passé
fasciste
tout le monde est donc on arrive à se
pardonner du coup la crèche est ouvert
le samedi tous les deux c'est pire que
nous et l'eau me font nelly est comme un
petit couple parce qu'en fait on se doit
nous dit ça sert à musique a dit ça je
trouve ça bidon quand même si la trousse
un but de wayne ans a fait les phrases
des mois non quand je dis en 2010 c'est
beau non non c'est ça que ça veut dire
les phrases ça fait belle pour permettre
au petit dans un journal ans c'était
juste pour dire que c'est vrai sinon
j'aurais une autre vie aurait peut-être
beaucoup moins joli que celle ci s'il
n'y avait pas ou sur les jours aux
galeries de sac
ouais ouais mais ce qu'il dit pas dans
son passé c'est quand même non non non
non non non question suivante j'allais
dire on n'en parle pas vous séparer
quand non non on a des projets encore
chanter en adrar bonne à un film qui qui
s'écrit en ce moment et qui va se
tourner cet été
ah bon ouais et avec christian fechner
donc c'est celui des charlots fechner
donc ouais ouais ouais c'est top voulu
nous les cherchons mais nous c'est
mortel alors vous avez un ça s'appelle
la tour montparnasse infernale non on va
faire